nicht nur jetzt zum parteitag haben sich
viele in der cdu gefragt ist das
eigentlich noch der friedrich merz den
wir gewählt haben zum vorsitzenden oder
hat sich sozusagen schon wieder
ausgemerzt in der cdu wir zeigen euch
was den alten friedrich merz dass ich
nicht der liebling des partei
establishments in berlin bilden das
wissen sie auch als diesen alten
friedrich merz unterscheidet von venue
friedrich merz neben der dicken brille
hier und dem
[Musik]
kommt man gleich noch mal darauf zurück
wir schauen aber auch was bedeutet
dieser wandel nicht nur für seine partei
die cdu sondern auch fürs land sprich wo
endet dieser neue friedrich merz im
abseits oder im kanzleramt was meint ihr
schreibt uns in die kommentare was wir
glauben und warum jetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich nehme das wahlergebnis an ja es war
ein historischer moment im dritten
anlauf wird friedrich merz vorsitzende
der cdu ein tränchen der rührung bei ihm
und große erleichterung bei all denen in
der cdu die sich unter der langjährigen
vorsitzenden angela merkel gefragt
hatten was ist eigentlich aus unserer
partei geworden ja wo ist das
konservative das was uns abgrenzt von
den anderen parteien viele haben sich
daran gestört dass merkel ihre politik
nicht vom parteiprogramm abgeleitet hat
sondern eher von stimmungen in der
bevölkerung von umfragen ja beispiel
atomausstieg beispiel aussetzung der
wehrpflicht und so weiter und das sollte
sich der märz fans nun alles wieder
besser werden jetzt nach einem guten
halben jahr aber sagen manche das ist ja
gar nicht mehr der friedrich merz nicht
mehr gewählt haben stimmt dass wir schon
auf drei beispiele bzw aspekte cancelte
die orientierung an meinungsumfragen und
die
[Musik]
ja kein thema in der cdu emotionalisiert
so stark und vor allem seit solange
darüber gestritten wird schon als er
hier
fraktionsvorsitzender war ja war ja
schon mal 2000 bis 22 und er war wie
auch viele andere konservative in der
partei immer eher skeptisch was eine
frauenquote angeht das gilt übrigens
auch für die junge union also die
jugendorganisation der partei für die 14
bis 35 jährigen die sind traditionell
trotz des jüngeren alters konservativer
unterwegs als die gesamtpartei ja und
dass er bei friedrich merz da für viele
in den letzten jahren ja so eine art
rockstar
[Applaus]
ja und bei dieser jungen union sind eben
ganz viele ausdrücklich gegen die quote
wir wollen am ende dafür sorgen dass
jeder eine chance hat aber dafür müssen
wir am ende auch bereit sein
ungleichheiten zu tolerieren liebe
freunde ja bloß ausgerechnet unter ihrem
friedrich merz fiel dann sozusagen im
partei ist der bestand die entscheidung
dass man doch eine quote einführen will
in der cdu schrittweise bis 20.25 ich
sage wenn du uns nichts besseres
einfällt bin ich auch dafür ja fanden
viele konservative in der partei nicht
so toll zumal es wenig später noch ein
anderes thema gab bei dem friedrich merz
manchen als umfaller vorkam stichwort
[Musik]
zitat die größte bedrohung für die
meinungsfreiheit ist aus meiner sicht
inzwischen die zensur kultur die man
auch cancel culture nennt zitat von
friedrich merz ein paar tagen danach
dann dass er sollte bei einer
veranstaltung ein gespräch mit ihm hier
haben den cgm ein tram partie da gab es
dann einige kritik vor allem von links
dass merz sich mit ihm treffen wollte
dann hat merz das gespräch abgesagt
offizielle begründung wegen des
geänderten programms der veranstaltung
da sollte nämlich noch andere
gesprächsrunde stattfinden unter anderem
eine mit chemie joachim steinhöfel der
als anwalt die afg vertreten hat da ist
brachte märz dann den vorwurf ein dass
er damit genau das getan habe was er
gerade noch kritisiert hatte nämlich
selbst einzuschränken wer zum
demokratischen spektrum gehört und wenn
nicht und dieser vor aufgaben unter
anderem von lindsey graham saved der
sagte richtung märz conservative don't
sleep aber bevor der ghettos peak ja und
auch in der cdu haben da einige den
friedrich merz vermisst der kurz zuvor
noch das hier gesagt hatte volkspartei
zu sein heißt ja nicht auf jede
auseinandersetzung mit dem
parteipolitischen gegner zu verzichten
sondern im gegenteil mit den eigenen
klaren überzeugungen diese
auseinandersetzung suchen ja wie seht
ihr das hätte merz den termin nicht
absagen dürfen muss man generell gefragt
mit allen reden sich mit allen
auseinandersetzen schreibt uns ja märz
hat jedenfalls in der cdu-zentrale im
konrad-adenauer-haus seinen büroleiter
von seinen aufgaben entbunden schon der
zweite wechsel auf dieser position die
vorgängerin war sogar nur ein paar
wochen im amt hoher verschleiß also und
für manchen die nervosität und dafür
dass er als parteivorsitzender noch
nicht so richtig angekommen ist dass da
in der zentrale nicht so wirklich viele
verbündete vertrauter hat nächster
vorwurf dass der neue märz
auseinandersetzung immer öfter aus dem
weg gehe
[Musik]
was viele seiner fans immer so toll
fanden märz ist dass er immer sehr klar
seine meinung sagt und die dann auch
sehr vehement vertritt und zwar egal was
alle anderen denken ja und da erscheint
sich durchaus ein bisschen was gewandelt
zu haben anhört neuerdings häufiger
sätze wie ich mir anschauen ich habe
dazu noch keine meinung ja das hätte man
von ihm tatsächlich früher eher selten
gehört und vor kurzem dann das hier da
hat er sich erst im bundestag so ein
bisschen lustig gemacht über annalena
baerbock beziehungsweise ihr konzept der
feministischen außenpolitiker mal sie
können von mir aus feministischer
außenpolitik machen feministische
entwicklungshilfepolitik das können sie
alles machen aber nicht mit diesem etat
für die bundeswehr war und dann hat
annalena baerbock darauf entgegnet dass
es ihr bei diesem konzept zum beispiel
darum gehe dass vergewaltigung nicht
mehr als kriegswaffe eingesetzt werden
deswegen gehört zu einer
sicherheitspolitik des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert auf eine feministische nicht
reisedienst
ja der alte märz der hätte jetzt
möglicherweise scharf nachgelegt der
neue sagte dagegen wenig später in einem
spiegel -interview frau berbalk haben
gut gekontert
na ja und so für minister schon
außenpolitik zitat ich habe nie
bestritten dass dieses konzept einen
platz in der außenpolitik haben muss red
devils new mester märz und diese ich
nenne es mal neue anpassungsfähigkeit
diese inhaltliche geschmeidigkeit die es
durchaus bei einigen themen zu
beobachten beispiel mindestlohn ja den
hat die ampel kürzlich im bundestag
beschlossen die wirtschaftsleute in der
cdu traditionell auch so eine art märz
fanclub die waren dagegen sagen dass es
sache von arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften nicht aufgabe der politik
und obwohl ihr friedrich merz jetzt
partei- und fraktionsvorsitzender ist
konnten sich diese wirtschaftsleute
nicht durchsetzen mit ihrer ablehnung
weil viele andere gesagt haben wir in
diesen zeiten gegen mindestlohn
erhöhungen zu sein das finden die leute
blöd also hat merz unionsfraktion sich
am ende enthalten im bundestag wo viele
dann gesagt haben das ist ja von der
taktik her recht marke pur sprich bloß
nicht von irgendwelchen grundsätzen
stören lassen sondern besser joseph low
tja und wenn ich mich so umhöre in der
cdu bei leuten die ihn gewählt haben da
sind einige schon auch wenn sie das
jetzt nicht offen vor der kamera sagen
wollen durchaus enttäuscht über das eine
oder andere was wiederum zur frage führt
warum dieser wandel bzw
ist es überhaupt ein echter wandel
[Musik]
man darf er nicht vergessen keineswegs
alle in der cdu sind jahrelange märz
fans zweimal hat die parteien ja als
vorsitzenden verhindert und mit jedem
zentimeter den er sich nun von seiner
eigenen fan base weg bewegt bewegt er
sich auf seine parteiinternen skeptiker
zu und so ist sein verhalten was jetzt
viele als wandlung wahrnehmen in
wahrheit ziemlich leicht zu verstehen
weil wenn der kanzlerkandidat der union
werden will und dass er das trotz seines
alters bei den nächsten bundestagswahl
wäre fast 70 wenn die regulär
stattfindet 20 25 das hat das trotz
seines alters durchaus für denkbar hält
das hat er schon gesagt ja und dafür
braucht er eben möglichst viel rückhalt
aus seiner partei nicht nur von denen
die ihn eh super finden er selbst sagt
vieles von diesem alten konservativen
image das sei ihm ohne ihn von außen
zugeschrieben worden wie auch immer
tatsächlich das höre ich jetzt von
vielen cdu leuten die nicht zum
traditionellen märz lager gehören die
auch noch bei der letzten wahl gegen ihn
gestimmt haben dass die sagen hoppla der
friedrich der hörte dazu verbindet ja
ein
finden wir gut
[Musik]
was also heißt das jetzt für die zukunft
ich würde sagen der alte friedrich merz
der hat sich selbst ein bisschen and
märz
ausgemerzt hat sie sich deswegen aber
nicht vielleicht sogar im gegenteil
stichwort kanzleramt ob sein kalkül
aufgeht das muss sich allerdings noch
zeigen denn es gibt ja auch noch ein
paar andere cdu leute die für die
nächste kanzlerkandidatur gehandelt
werden er hier zum beispiel oder auch er
und über diese internen konkurrenten
sagt der neue märz ganz galant er freue
sich über jeden der wahlerfolg hat in
der cdu und insofern freue ich mich auch
über jeden der dazu kommt klar was
natürlich sehr charmant ist war
vielleicht schon auch ein klitzekleines
bisschen geflunkert vielleicht ja auch
immer seine andere rolle die als
fraktionsvorsitzende die nutzer
jedenfalls emsig um sich seinen schatten
kanzler zu präsentieren aber ein cash
als scholz noch nicht hinwollte beim
thema waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
das erkannte auch der abend noch sehr
zögerlich war dann antrag für den
bundestag vorbereitet und damit scholz
und die ampel sozusagen zum handeln
gezwungen man könnte hier auch noch eine
andere beispiele nennen sondern für den
bundeswehr zb trotzdem und auch trotz
der ziemlich niedrige zustimmungswerte
die die ampel parteien gerade haben ja
so eine klare wechselstimmung hin zur
union und zu märz die es nicht ablesbar
an den aktuellen umfrage werden schauen
wir mal drauf also deutlich zugelegt hat
die union seit der wahl schon aber eine
klare wechselstimmung würde ich da
derzeit jedenfalls nicht ablesen weder
an den partei werden noch an merz
persönlichen beliebtheitswerten
interessant dazu hatte pionieren bemerkt
diese schlechten beliebtheitswerte von
friedrich merz die sind sehr konstant
gab es so ähnlich auch schon damals also
zum ersten mal fraktionsvorsitzender war
[Musik]
ja ist ja noch ein bisschen hin bis zur
nächsten bundestagswahl insofern jetzt
eine präzise vorhersage zu machen ist
ehrlicherweise nicht möglich klar ist
nur den weg dahin wien hat er sich durch
seine ich würde mal sagen behutsame and
märz um auf jeden fall offen gehalten
vielleicht sogar eher verbreitert egal
wie viel kalkül jetzt dahinter steckt
und wie viele echte wandlung dass er
sein altes image als hardliner als mann
ohne selbstironie dass ihr dieses image
selbst korrigieren ja so ein bisschen ab
soften wollte das glaube ich steht
allerdings außer frage lässt sich zum
beispiel daran sehen dass sind eigene
social media team das hier ausgegeben
hat
[Musik]
das hat christian lindner noch mal
gesagt ist es besser nicht zu tanzen
das war eigentlich auch anders egal was
glaubt ihr der neue märz wird der
kanzlerkandidat am ende gar kanzler
schreibt uns eure prognosen in die
kommentare
wir bleiben natürlich dran an dem thema
nicht nur in dem daher lasst uns gern
aber da und sehr gern natürlich auch ein
like und dann würde ich vorschlagen alle
zusammen
[Musik]